bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro des grands débats nous allons
revoir l'année parlementaire à travers
un moment phare à l'Assemblée nationale
les questions au Gouvernement chaque
mardi lorsque la session est ouverte
députée interroge les ministres sur
l'actualité politique économique ou
sociale au titre de leur pouvoir de
contrôle
nous sommes en juillet 2022 la question
du pouvoir d'achat domine dans un
contexte de crise énergétique causée en
partie par la guerre en Ukraine de
nombreuses interrogations de députés ce
qui donne lieu à une séance électrique
ce mois de juillet regardez
100 euros pour faire un plein 2000 euros
pour remplir la cuve de fioul 200 euros
de plus par mois pour faire les courses
l'inflation galopante et les taxes
plombent le pouvoir d'achat des Français
avec des spéculateurs sans scrupules qui
se gavent au passage c'est à croire
d'ailleurs que tout se fabrique en
Ukraine en Russie madame la Première
ministre le budget des ménages explose
et il est temps d'agir vite et fort en
revalorisant les pensions des retraités
et des personnes en situation de
handicap en baissant les charges comme
la CSG pour les retraités les salariés
et les népendam en neutralisant le prix
des carburants à 1 euro 50 à la pompe
tout ce qui ont besoin de leur voiture
au quotidien c'est 80% des Français le
savent un litre de carburant C 60% de
taxes alors madame la Première ministre
combien de temps encore allez-vous
pomper des milliards d'euros sur le dos
des Français
la vraie différence entre le chemin que
vous proposez et le nôtre c'est que vous
promettez aux Français des dépenses qui
consiste à leur reprendre dans quelques
années par des impôts ce que vous leur
promettez aujourd'hui
c'est exactement ce que vous faites vous
nous avez accusé de vouloir cramer la
caisse mais vous voulez faire sauter la
banque et c'est les Français qui
payeraient avec des impôts ce que vous
promettez
donc oui nous allons continuer à agir
avec un plan massif massif 46 milliards
d'euros au total qui auront été investis
pour permettre aux Français de dépenser
moins de gagner plus c'est ça la
cohérence de notre action et nous nous
ne mentons pas aux Français
soit 64 milliards d'euros de recettes
fiscales supplémentaires en 2021 par
rapport à 2017 où je le rappelle vous
avez augmenté de 20 centimes la
fiscalité sur les carburants c'est ça la
réalité de votre politique fiscale plus
de 50 milliards de recettes attendues
nouvelle en 2022 grâce à nos acteurs
économiques qui sont lourdement taxés
mais qui vont au charbon tous les matins
alors stop à l'infumage rendez l'argent
en français d'abord merci monsieur le
député de saluer enfin la qualité du
bilan de cette majorité sur l'emploi
puisque les recettes fiscales
supplémentaires que vous évoquez elles
sont liées au fait que nous avons le
taux de chômage le plus bas depuis 15
ans le taux de chômage des jeunes le
plus bas depuis 40 ans le taux d'emploi
le plus haut depuis qu'il est mesuré
donc quand vous saluez la qualité de
cette action vous saluez ce que nous
avons fait et ce que nous avons porté
merci beaucoup agir pour le pouvoir
d'achat avec efficacité et durabilité
implique d'agir avec nos finances
publiques
la responsabilité nous devons aussi pour
cette protection à nos concitoyens aussi
pourriez-vous monsieur le ministre ici
rassurer cette immense majorité de
Françaises et de français et exposé les
mesures et plan d’action envisagés pour
développer le plein emploi premier moyen
pour selon nous d'une augmentation
efficiente du pouvoir d'achat et
d'entamer une véritable baisse de notre
déficit public en réaffirmant devant la
représentation nationale que
l'engagement pris et entrepris sous le
précédent quinquennat à savoir pas de
hausse d'impôts ni de creusement de la
dette sera poursuivie moi je veux
insister sur le fait que l'inflation en
France est inférieure de deux points à
celle de la zone euro c'est grâce à
l'action de ce gouvernement et de cette
majorité qui a permis de bloquer un
certain nombre de prix qui se seraient
envolés si nous n'avions pas agi il
suffit de regarder autour de nous dans
les pays qui nous entourent pour le
mesurer nous allons continuer résolument
sur cette voie continuez à tout faire et
vous l'avez appelé de vos vœux pour
investir et agir pour toi nous allons
continuer à agir pour la compétitivité
de nos entreprises en proposant
notamment la suppression de la CVAE la
baisse des impôts de production pour que
nos entreprises puissent continuer à
agir j'étais hier aux côtés du Président
de la République pour le sommet de
choses France avec des chefs
d'entreprise de grands groupes
internationaux qu'est-ce qui nous ont
dit ils nous ont dit que depuis quelques
années la France a retrouvé une
attractivité qui leur donne envie de
venir investir en France ça fait trois
ans que les baromètres internationaux
nous classent comme pays le plus
attractif d'Europe pour les
investissements étrangers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des loyers ni d'être ni impôts mais des
dispositifs qui auront des effets
rapides positifs et ce grâce au projet
de loi sur le pouvoir d'achat symbole
d'une politique volontariste concrète et
responsable c'est ce que nous devons
français c'est ce que nous devons à
notre pays aussi Monsieur le Ministre
pourriez-vous nous indiquer les
différentes modalités de mise en oeuvre
de ces mesures et leur calendrier je
vous remercie
la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat que nous
défendons devant votre commission hier
soir que vous allez examiner de
l'article par article dans les heures
qui viennent tiens les engagements pris
par le Président de la République
pendant la campagne ces engagements sont
tenus dans le domaine énergétique Agnès
manière une archi la rappeler sont une
dans le domaine économique et ils seront
évidemment tenues pour les revenus du
travail nous allons et vous l'avez dit
revaloriser les pensions de retraite et
les prestations sociales de 4% et
j'ajoute que cette revalorisation de 4%,
ça joue à une première revalorisation de
1,1% pour les retraites au début de
l'année et de 1,8% pour présentation
sociale au mois d'avril dernier nous
allons favoriser le partage de la valeur
avec le triplement des plafonds de la
prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat
mais aussi en simplifiant de manière
drastique les conditions qui permettent
aux entreprises de mettre en place des
accords d'intéressement jusque dans les
entreprises de 5 grandes salariés pour
que la valeur soit mieux partagée que
les richesses produites soient mieux
partagées nous allons aussi faire en
sorte de dynamiser les grilles
salariales et des mesures sont prévues
aussi pour que la revalorisation
automatique du SMIC puisse se traduire
plus concrètement par une véritable
dynamique en matière de convention
salariale et de convention collective et
puis enfin nous tenons un autre
engagement du Président de la République
cet engagement c'est celui qui va
permettre aux travailleurs indépendants
de gagner plus chaque année ces
engagements sont tenus ils sont tenus
grâce à la mobilisation de la majorité
sont aussi tenus grâce à l'implication
de tous les responsables de groupes qui
avec vous et avec les rapporteurs
travaillent pour trouver les consensus
travaillent pour trouver les
convergences de façon à ce que ce
service rendu au français soit le plus
rassemble impossible l'inflation atteint
des niveaux historique alors que les
salaires n'augmentent pas les
mobilisations pour les housses de
salaire se multiplient ces mobilisation
sont sur l'ensemble du territoire et
dans tous les secteurs tous sans
exceptions demandent une revalorisation
des salaires je dis bien des salaires
vous ne proposez que des chèques
aléatoires et des primes au bon vouloir
des employeurs ce n'est pas avec des
primes et des chèques qu'on paye son
loyer tous les mois ce n'est pas avec
des primes et des chèques que l'on fait
le plein de la semaine ce n'est pas avec
des primes et des chèques que l'on
nourrit ses enfants tous les jours avec
mes camarades femmes de chambre nous
avons porté ce combat pour les salaires
et nous l'avons gagné
au sein de la nups nous souhaitons
porter ce combat pour l'ensemble des
travailleurs et travailleuses nous la
lups nous proposons l'augmentation du
SMIC à 1500 euros on doit organiser une
conférence de salaire général et
d'obliger l'égalité des traitement entre
salariés des entreprises et des
sous-traitants nous avons un mécanisme
de protection du niveau du SMIC ce
mécanisme de protection du niveau du
SMIC qui prévoit des revalorisations
automatiques dès lors que l'inflation
dépasse un certain niveau a été mise en
oeuvre deux fois et cela a permis sur
les 10 derniers mois l'augmentation du
SMIC à hauteur de 5,9%. soit
l'équivalent de l'inflation et c'est une
bonne chose que les salariés qui sont
salariés au salaire minimum puisse voir
ainsi leur pouvoir d'achat protéger nous
avons aussi d'autres règles des règles
qui permettent pardonnez-moi madame mais
je réponds à Madame la Députée si vous
voulez bien laisser votre collègue
écoutez ma réponse ça sera signe de
politesse et de respect et donc je le
disais le mécanisme augmentation du Smic
amène un certain nombre de branches
avoir des minimad branches qui passent
sous le SMIC dans le cas de du comité de
suivi négociation salariale nous
veillons à ce que les branches repassent
au niveau du SMIC j'ai moi-même présidé
ce comité jeudi dernier les branches
font le travail et dans le projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat que je vous invite à
voter il y a aussi des mesures
d'incitation et de restructuration des
branches
grâce à notre mobilisation sans faille
nous et oui c'est bien nous les
républicains qui avons obtenu de réelles
avancées pour les Français
en obtenant une ristourne de l'état de
30 centimes par litre contre 18 au début
et une remise de 20 centimes de total
soit une baisse de 50 centimes par litre
de carburant à la pompe qui sera
effective dès septembre j'ajoute
également les 230 millions d'euros
d'aide pour les ménages qui se chauffent
au fioul et les 15 millions d'euros de
soutien aux stations-service en milieu
rural je le dis haut et fort il est
vital de redonner du pouvoir d'achat à
tous les Français je pense en
particulier aux habitants dans nos
territoires ruraux asphyxiés par
l'inflation et des taxes record
il souffre plus spécifiquement cependant
ces mesures vont dans le bon sens ne
sont qu'un début elle ne saurait être
suffisante sur le long terme seriez-vous
donc prêtes madame la Première ministre
a baissé de manière pérenne les taxes
sur les carburants comme nous vous le
demandons depuis plusieurs semaines déjà
enfin alors que la ristourne à la pompe
doit s'arrêter en fin d'année
pouvez-vous clairement nous garantir
qu'elle sera prolongée si les prix du
pétrole ne baisse toujours pas d'ici là
nous continuons à agir et à prendre des
mesures adaptées c'est tout le sens des
travaux qui nous ont réunis vous l'avez
dit c'est dernier jour nous avions une
proposition qui était d'étendre
progressivement la ristourne carburant
et de lui substituer un nouveau
dispositif il y a eu des échanges et
effectivement notamment avec votre
groupe nous avons adopté un autre
dispositif qui est la prolongation de la
ristourne carburant sont renforcement
total est venu aussi apporter une
ristourne supplémentaire qui fait comme
vous l'avez dit au mois de septembre
c'est 50 centimes de baisse au litre
c'est massif et là il y a aussi peu de
comparable au niveau européen je veux le
souligner je veux souligner les autres
amendements qui sont venus enrichir vous
avez cité celui de Monsieur desker donc
nous avons toujours montré que nous
répondions présents mais nous avons
aussi toujours dit la vérité aux
Français ça n'est pas vrai de dire que
l'État peut seul prendre à sa charge les
effets de l'inflation nous ne pouvons
pas faire croire cela aux Français parce
que la réalité c'est que nous devons
aussi tenir nos finances publiques pour
ne pas reporter des impôts sur les
années et les générations suivantes il
faut assumer nos responsabilités et donc
la ligne qui est la nôtre c'est aussi de
faire participer les entreprises nous
avons adopté cette initiative de
plusieurs groupes de cette hémicycle
dont le vôtre un abonnement qui permet
de doubler la prime défiscalisée pour
les entreprises pour aider leurs
salariés en matière de carburant vous
voyez nous continuons à agir tous
ensemble monsieur le ministre il y a des
priorités aider les Français sur ce
thème et je le rappelle c'est la
mobilisation des républicains AINS qui a
permis d'arriver à CEBS il faut
simplement pérenniser ces messes c'est
important pour les Français merci
un sujet sensible résonne à l'Assemblée
nationale celui de la violence faite aux
femmes Aurore Bergé présidente du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale
évoque l'affaire Adrien cattenens député
LFI du Nord visée par une plainte pour
violence conjugale applaudi par la
majorité la question d'Aurore berger
suscite un tollé en séance
depuis plusieurs semaines on loue la
vertu de celui qui reconnaît des faits
de violence conjugales depuis plusieurs
semaines on entend ce qui parle de leur
affection pour un homme qui frappe sa
femme depuis plusieurs semaines on fait
fi des règles élémentaires de l'État de
droit on jette le discrédit sur les
femmes et les hommes policiers et
gendarmes qui au périls de leur vie
interviennent après des signalements de
violences conjugales on jette le discret
dit sur l'institution judiciaire on
jette en fait des dizaines d'années de
combats de nos associations qui ont
permis aux victimes d'être accompagnés
par la seule voie qui peut mettre un
terme à leur souffrance la voie
judiciaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois que ce sujet appelle le calme
et non le trouble ou le désordre je
crois que ce sujet mérite mieux que des
esclandre et je suis navré que vous
reconnaissiez si bien dans les propos
que j'ai exprimé
est-ce que tout fonctionne aujourd'hui
madame la Première ministre la réponse
est non mais est-ce que des progrès ont
été accomplis la réponse est oui le
conjoint violent doit quitté le domicile
nos policiers gendarmes et magistrats
sont formés les dépôts de plainte sont
facilités jusque dans nos hôpitaux les
téléphones graves dangers sont déployés
alors oui oui nous devons faire mieux et
ça commence par nos attitudes ça
commence par les mots que nous employons
ça commence pas de respecter les
victimes ça commence par le fait merci
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et la grande cause des quinquennats
d'Emmanuel Macron nous avons agi dans
tous les domaines nous avons agi aussi
avec force contre toutes les formes de
violence sexistes et sexuelles
et je sais madame la Présidente Aurore
berger votre engagement personnel pour
ce combat et je veux le saluer avec le
Grenelle des violences conjugales nous
avons obtenu de nombreux avancées pour
que la parole se libère et que chaque
victime puisse être prise en charge nous
avons étendu les horaires du 39 19 mis
en place une plateforme de signalement
en ligne favoriser la prise de plainte
et lancer la création d'un fichier des
mises en cause s'il vous plaît mes chers
c'est en effet un sujet sérieux et je
voudrais continuer à vous préciser les
actions qui ont été engagées depuis 2017
madame bobolo
[Applaudissements]
donc pour le traitement des plinthes
pour mieux protéger les victimes nous
avons formé près de 160 000 policiers et
gendarmes déployés des téléphones graves
dangers et des bracelets anti
rapprochement mais tant qu'il y aura des
coups nous continuerons 10000 places
d'hébergement seront ouvertes dès cette
année et j'ai annoncé le mois dernier
l'ouverture de 1000 places
supplémentaires en 2023 nous allons
doubler la présence policière dans la
rue nous voulons améliorer notre réponse
et nos procédures pénales et je le
rappelle vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente berger en ces domaines seul
institution judiciaire peut déterminer
les faits dire le droit et sanctionner
à l'automne 2022 le sujet de
l'immigration clandestine s'invite à
l'Assemblée nationale alors que le
bateau Ocean Viking a fêté par
l'association SOS Méditerranée a appelé
la France à l'aide pour pouvoir accoster
sur les côtes françaises avec à son bord
de 134 passagers alors qu'il est en
train d'évoquer le sort de ces migrants
bloqués en mer le député à la fille
Carlos Martin belongo est interrompu par
un député du rassemblement national qui
l'invective avec ses mots qu'il retourne
en Afrique
l'indignation est-elle dans l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale que la
présidente est contrainte de suspendre
la séance sans la rouvrir un fait inédit
sous la 5e République
sont bloqués sur le pont du bateau
depuis 11 jours depuis 11 jours ils
attendent de pouvoir débarquer dans un
port sur j'aimerais dire à la collègue à
ce moment national qui du haut du père
soit de la Semaine Nationale croit
pouvoir organiser les opérations de
sauvetage en Méditerranée avec la plus
grande désinvolture et sans d'autres
mérites dans sa vie que d'être né dans
un pays en paix je vous le dis ne vous
en déplaise leur vie compte
l'océan de Viking a adressé aujourd'hui
c'est la 7ème du monde d'assistance aux
autorités maritimes italiennes quel sera
donc l'action du Gouvernement sur ce
sujet quelle forme prendra la
coopération avec Italie allez vous vous
saisir de la question de la répartition
des migrants avec et d'autres pays
européens comme Malte qui ne répond plus
aux demandes de cortisone sauvetage les
personnes secourues se trouvent dans une
situation d'urgence absolue des
prévisions météo indiquent une
détérioration significative du climat
pas du tout
c'est
[Applaudissements]
quel est le député qui vient de
prononcer cette phrase
pardon
attendez mes chers
[Applaudissements]
suspension de séance de 5 minutes je
vous promenais de l'événement grave qui
vient de se dérouler d'une part de
renvoyer cette question au prochain
Bureau qui a lieu mercredi pour le
prochain donc ce mercredi et qui est à
mon sens à même de pouvoir déterminer si
les faits qui ont été commis à l'instant
sont passifs d'une sanction et de quelle
sanction ils sont passives je vous
propose compte tenu de l'émotion
légitime qui s'est emparée de l'ensemble
des membres de assemblées de l'ensemble
du gouvernement de suspendre la séance
de questions au gouvernement
l'immigration est un sujet dominant de
ces questions d'automne le gouvernement
a d'ailleurs déposé un projet de loi
avec deux intentions accorder un titre
de séjour pour les travailleurs dans les
secteurs dit en tension par exemple la
restauration mais aussi accélérer les
reconduites à la frontière
la France est un pays d'immigration
politique humanitaire culturelle mais
aussi économique bien entendu qu'on ne
peut pas accueillir la terre entière et
qu'il faut des limites fermes envers
ceux qui ne sont pas autorisés à
demeurer dans notre pays mais à Angers
comme partout en France nous sommes
confrontés à une réalité d'emplois non
pourvu de tension sur de nombreux
bassins d'emplois et qui nuitent à
l'activité de nos entreprises et
parallèlement à ces difficultés de
recrutement nous avons des étrangers qui
sont en capacité de travailler ou qui
travaillent qui travaillent parfois en
situation irrégulière pouvez-vous nous
préciser vos axes de travail et la
méthode que vous envisagez pour avancer
sur ce sujet qui peut et qui est déjà
instrumentalisé par une partie de la
classe politique à droite et à l'extrême
droite alors que le sujet est important
pour nombre de d'étrangers pour nombre
d'entreprises nous avons absolument
besoin d'avancer nous y sommes prêts
vous y êtes nous sommes à vos côtés
merci mais le ministre de l'Intérieur
nous vous présenter effectivement à sa
tente de pistes relatives à la réforme
de l'immigration que nous allons
conduire et conduire avec le Parlement
parmi ces pistes il y a évidemment la
nécessité de mieux faire respecter nos
règles et de me faire appliquer les
décisions il y a aussi la volonté
d'intégrer les étrangers présents sur
notre territoire par le travail cela
passe par des simplifications notamment
en matière d'accès au travail de
dispense de demande d'autorisation pour
les immigrer au titre de la vie
économique cela passe aussi par la
possibilité que nous voulons ouvrir de
permettre à des travailleurs aujourd'hui
irréguliers mais exerçant dans des
secteurs en tension de recrutement de
pouvoir connaître une admission
exceptionnelle au séjour sur le modèle
de ce qui est fait par la circulaire de
2012 est-ce qu'il s'agit de
régularisation massive non il s'agit
d'études au cas par cas en fonction de
l'ancien test sur le territoire et de
l'occupation d'un emploi dans des
métiers en tension il s'agit d'apporter
des réponses des réponses à des chefs
d'entreprise qui recrutent mais des
réponses aussi à des hommes et des
femmes qui sont intégrés travaillent sur
notre territoire souhaite continuer à le
faire dans des bonnes conditions il
s'agit d'accompagner les employeurs mais
aussi les salariés concernés puisque en
permettant à ces salariés de demander
eux-mêmes leur régularisation à ce titre
nous pouvons dans des cas extrêmement
minoritaires mais qui existent les
soustraire à la domination de certains
employeurs qui peuvent être un délicats
je le répète ces minoritaires mais ça
existe
en faisant cette fois Coster l'océan
Viking dans le port militaire de Toulon
pour le soustraire à la vue de tous vous
faites basculer le pays à l'heure où
tous les peuples européens dis STOP à
l'immigration massive la France se pose
comme le pays qui encourage la
clandestinité épouse de pauvres gens à
risquer leur vie les trafiquants d'êtres
humains ont gagné les ONG sont leurs
complicités désormais vous aussi vous
attaquez l'Italie qui submergé depuis 10
ans n'en veut plus et ce à leur même que
son peuple la signifiait dans les urnes
il y a encore un mois que dites-vous
madame la Premier ministre à vos amis de
Malte qui n'en veulent pas non plus rien
à la Tunisie dans les ports étaient les
plus proches au moment du sauvetage rien
et que dites-vous à la Norvège dont le
pavillon permet à cette ONG de naviguer
impunément toujours rien madame la
Premier ministre vous ne faites rien les
centres de rétention explosent vous
expulsez personne nos policiers
travaillent dans le vide d'une justice
qui ne suit plus les préfectures
débordent tandis qu' ancien ministre et
préfet défile dans les médias pour
décrire l'inimaginable votre politique
s'est accueillir et rép artir le
rassemblement national lui veut secourir
et reconduire finalement une question
est simple si vous étiez responsabilité
auriez-vous laissé mourir c'est 44
enfants
permettez-moi de faire le point sur
votre travail chaos Stade de France
mensonges d'État sur les supporters
anglais explosion des atteintes aux
personnes pearchives sécurité depuis des
décennies
humiliation par un imam étranger abandon
de Mayotte crise migratoire dans la
Manche et accostage de bateau de
migrants dans le sud dans une démocratie
normale on aurait des vous n'êtes pas
prêt aux responsabilités madame parce
que vous ne vous répondez pas à cette
question simple de la décision politique
une décision politique ne vit pas dans
le monde incroyable des réunions du
Front national entre personnes qui sont
d'accord entre personnes qui disent
qu'il faut qu'il retourne de là où ils
viennent madame la vérité madame la
députée c'est que nous avons fait preuve
d'humanisme quand vous faites de la
politique politicienne et je m'en
d'orgueille madame la députée que soit
cette majorité qui se pouvoir pour
sauver ses enfants là avec vous on sait
ce qui serait devenu
en cet automne budgétaire alors que les
députés sont en plein examen de la loi
de finances l'inflation et ses
conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat sont
au cœur des préoccupations mais les
questions du mardi sont aussi l'occasion
pour les députés d'interpeller le
gouvernement sur des questions très
diverses florilège
300 gendarmes policiers militaires
français sont affectés à la sécurité de
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar c'est
personnels français vous disaient
vont-ils permettre aux personnes
lgbtqia plus de vivre sur place en
sécurité pourront-ils brandir un drapeau
aux couleurs LGBT pourront-ils et elles
s'embrasser dans la rue sous la
protection et vous installez dans le
calme s'il vous plaît pourront-ils
demander l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre en cas de discrimination dans
l'accès aux chambres d'hôtel je rappelle
que l'affirmation d'une sexualité LGBT
et non seulement illégale au Qatar mais
peut conduire à de l'emprisonnement et
la peine de mort pour les personnes de
confusion de confession musulmanes selon
le gardien les autorités catary ne se
contenteraient pas d'arrêter violenter
les personnels GBT elles auraient mis en
place un système sordide visant à les
obliger à dénoncer d'autres personnes
LGBT pour échapper aux tortures la FIFA
quant à elle a interdit explicitement le
port du brassard Juan love ce qui
annonce rien de bon quand au respect des
droits des personnes
LGBT phobie est un délit en France ma
question est donc simple la garantie des
droits des personnels LGBT fait-elle
partie des missions confiées aux forces
de l'ordre français 20000 français vont
pouvoir assister au match de la Coupe du
monde de football c'est policiers ces
gendarmes sont là pour les accompagner
accompagner les autorités consulaires
sur l'autorité de la mise à faire
étrangère pour retrouver les documents
identité pour les accompagner vers
l'aéroport en cas de difficultés
évidemment pour déposer plainte si
jamais il devait connaître des
difficultés au Qatar c'est notamment la
France et notamment les gendarmes
français qui ont la politique antidrone
de la Coupe du monde de football c'est à
dire que il protège l'intégralité des
sites et notamment des sites aériens des
stades de football du Qatar ou des
grandes équipes en de football notamment
notre équipe de France sur place le
troisième raison pour laquelle les
gendarmes et les policiers français sont
là c'est notamment la formation qu'ils
ont pu avoir sur les motocyclistes qui
accompagnaient les délégations vous
voyez enfin quatrième sujet le GIGN qui
est là pour intervenir notamment pour
protéger l'équipe de France de football
ou ses supporters en cas d'attaque entre
nos intérêts en aucun cas les policiers
gendarmes français ne font du matcha de
l'ordre au Qatar en aucun cas ils sont
en contact avec la police qatari pour
appliquer les lois du Qatar ils sont là
pour protéger nos concitoyens et pour
nous aider à mieux organiser la Coupe du
monde de rugby et les Jeux olympiques
mais en fait vous n'avez pas du tout
répondu à la question est-ce qu'il les
protégeront en cas de LGBT phobie dans
la rue katari c'est ça la question
à Mayotte chaque jour nos enfants vont à
l'école la peur au ventre parce que les
établissements scolaires sont attaqués
les entreprises sont incendiées les
automobilistes sont agressés par des
hordes de jeunes démons qui se déplacent
par centaines des barbares en culotte
courte de 12 à 13 ans armés de machettes
de barres de fer de cailloux qui tuent
qui piquent qui agresse qui détruisent
et sème le chaos des mineurs des jeunes
adultes la plupart étrangers en
situation irrégulière que nous appelons
terroristes parce qu'ils mettent notre
île à feu et à sang et sème la terreur
pour nous faire fuir alors depuis
plusieurs mois en caillasses les bus
scolaires et on attaque les collèges et
les lycées maintenant on y entre à la
machette quand dites-vous trop c'est
trop
en début d'année des morceaux de corps
humain ont été déposés en évidence sur
la route pour terroriser la population à
Mayotte maintenant deux personnes ont
été torturées et amputées à la machette
en quelques jours seulement quel acte de
barbarie supplémentaire faut-il pour que
la République réagisse le ministère de
l'Intérieur vient d'envoyer des renforts
et me nous en remercions mais quand
allez-vous ordonner le déploiement de la
Marine nationale pour protéger notre
frontière et donner des moyens à la
justice pour opérer dans notre
département madame la Première ministre
qu'entendez-vous faire pour éviter la
guerre civile à Mayotte
nous avons plusieurs évidemment pistes
d'évolution j'en suis entretenu avec
vous lorsque je suis venu à Mayotte et
le président de la République lui-même
président qu'il va dessiner au
territoire omaoré d'abord des
renforcements très importants des mains
de la justice le Garde des Sceaux est
l'occasion d'évoquer les centres
éducatifs fermés à Mayotte mais aussi en
nombre de magistrats et en nombre de
décisions que pour en prendre pour
répondre au rendez-vous des une relation
qui sont nombreuses je le répète pour
mémoire en 2021 29000 interpellation
d'étrangers régulières
23724 reconduite à la frontière 325
opérations évidemment de police ces
trois derniers mois et ce plan
judiciaire 324 passeurs dont quatre
filières qui avaient une réaction
criminelle à leur tête et notamment
domicile et d'actes de barbarie qui ont
été interpellés il faut les présenter à
la justice et ses moyens je le sais de
garder ceux et réfléchit sous l'autorité
du Président de la République sur le
côté militaire vous avez parfaitement
raison nous avons entendu votre demande
et avec le ministre des Armées nous
travaillons d'ailleurs en partie ce soir
à lors de l'élaboration d'un lot de
programmation militaire qu'un chapitre
particulier puisse se tenir pour la
Guyane et pour Mayotte pour renforcer
les moyens militaires il appartiendra
ministre des Armées évidemment
d'annoncer ses moyens mais je crois
qu'ils vont dans le sens de vos demandes
et puis troisième sujet pour nous c'est
une opération vous le savez sur lequel
travaille l'État allemand du président
de la République de mettre fin au bon
gars sur une partie en tout cas du
territoire mahorais une opération de
grande envergure où nous enverrons
beaucoup de gendarmes de gendarmes
mobiles mais de moyens de l'État pour
effectivement inverser la courbe de la
violence monsieur
le ministre relative le fonctionnement
du marché du travail en vue du plein
emploi avec ce texte l'objectif est
d'aller vers le plaid emploi objectif
crédible atteignable avec un taux de
chômage de 7,4% au deuxième trimestre
2022 et dans ma propre circonscription
de 4,3 % tous les plus bas depuis 15 ans
avec notamment le recul du chômage des
jeunes des seniors et des personnes
handicapées en 2022 Emmanuel Macron
proposait une modification du système
d'assurance chômage plus stricte qu'en
trop d'emploi sont non pourvus plus
généreuses quand le chômage est élevé la
déclinaison de cette loi était
travaillée en concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux vous avez pu définir
un plan d'action pouvez-vous nous en
donner le contenu les modalités et
l'échéancier d'autre part avez-vous
envisagé des mesures spécifiques pour
les personnes les plus éloignées de
l'emploi nécessitant un accompagnement
plus long et adapté notre objectif est
clair c'est avoir un système plus
incitatif quand les choses ont bien sur
le marché de l'emploi c'est le cas
aujourd'hui d'avoir un système plus
protecteur quand les choses vont mal et
c'est ce que nous avons adopté avec vous
permet de d'appliquer cette règle tout
au long de l'année 2023 il faudra
ensuite que les partenaires sociaux
reprennent leurs compétences dans le
cadre du paritarisme et prolonge cet
élan dans le cadre d'un documentation
que nous leur donnerons les premiers
résultats sont là en termes d'emploi et
nous sommes malheureusement pas
suffisants puisque même si le taux de
chômage a baissé de 9,5 à 7,3 % nous
avons encore beaucoup de chômage mais
nous avons aussi beaucoup de tension de
recrutement alors que en moyenne 600 000
demandeurs d'emploi et avaient accès à
une formation pendant cette période
d'indemnisation entre octobre 2021 et
octobre 2022 ce sont un million 600 000
demandeurs d'emploi que nous avons
formés nous allons continuer à le faire
avec une garantie une certitude c'est
que nul n'est-il d'employable et que le
chemin du plein emploi est devant nous
une récente étude de l'Insee montre que
votre politique fiscale a surtout
profité au plus riche et Louis Gallois
qui n'est pas un gauchiste résume bien
ce sentiment d'injustice on tape sur les
plus précaires ont taxe pas les
surprofis mais on taxe les chômeurs il y
a un problème
la période de Noël approche combien
n'auront rien ou si peu à se mettre sous
le sapin je veux vous parler de la prime
de Noël seulement 2 millions de Français
la touchera elle ne sera pas versée à
ceux qui touchent une retraite de misère
aux jeunes sans ressources ni aux
personnes handicap ce n'est pas normal
ce n'est pas juste je vous demande donc
de l'élargir à tous les bénéficiaires
des minima sociaux et il faut la
revaloriser elle ne l'a pas été depuis
2007 avec l'inflation elle doit passer à
200 euros
une réponse rapide surtout pour les plus
fragiles et c'est pour cela que nous
avons décidé dès cet été de revaloriser
de manière anticipée les prestations
sociales à hauteur de 4%. elles seront
naturellement revalorisées à nouveau au
premier avril prochain à hauteur de
l'inflation c'est pour cela que nous
avons pris les mesures les plus
protectrices d'Europe pour limiter la
hausse des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité c'est pour cela que nous
avons revalorisé de 50% au 1er novembre
la location de soutien familial pour les
parents qui élèvent seuls leurs enfants
et c'est pour cela aussi que nous avons
mis en place une aide exceptionnelle de
solidarité qui a bénéficié à 11 millions
de personnes et le 15 décembre prochain
nous verserons de manière automatique la
prime de Noël à plus de 2,3 millions de
ménages notamment les bénéficiaires du
RSA ou de la location Spécifique de
Solidarité ça représente 500 millions
d'euros cette prime traduit l'engagement
constant de mon gouvernement à soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages et
accompagner ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin nous ne laisserons personne au
bord du chemin je vous remercie
décembre 2022 les fêtes de fin d'année
approchent et avec elle les craintes de
coupure d'électricité les députés sont
nombreux à interpeller le gouvernement
sur le sujet alors que le gestionnaire
du réseau RTE a prévu dans le pire des
cas une saison glaciale avec des
délaissages fréquents autre sujet de
préoccupation la hausse des prix qui
impacte très fortement les artisans de
France notamment les boulangers
la baguette vient d'être reconnue à
l'Unesco et c'est dans son propre pays
la France qu'elle est en danger
aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a
entendu en danger parce qu'il y a une
explosion des coudes électricité dans
les boulangeries tout simplement parce
que pour faire cuire du pain il faut un
four qui est une puissance supérieure à
celle qui est permise dans les tarifs
réglementés alors face à cette situation
les boulangers ont deux solutions soit
faire tendre le prix la baguette vers 2
euros soit mettre la clé sous la porte
ces deux options sont inattendables
madame la Première ministre nous vous le
demandons solennellement avec le groupe
des députés socialistes et apparentés
nous voulons un bouclier tarifaire avec
un tarif réglementé pour les
boulangeries et je souhaite votre
réponse sur ce point je vous remercie
j'ai moi-même reçu avec Olivia Grégoire
longuement les représentants des
boulangers Olivia Grégoire les recevra à
nouveau pour trouver des solutions
particulières pour les boulangers qui
effectivement sont confrontés au
problème que vous avez parfaitement
décrit de l'explosion de cool
l'électricité et des fours qui doivent
bien tourner pour faire cuire le pain la
première réponse c'est le guichet que
nous avons mis en place et j'invite
toutes les PME toutes les TP qui n'ont
pas encore fait elles sont très
nombreuses à venir déposer leurs
factures pour 2022 pour bénéficier des
aides dont elles peuvent bénéficier
jusqu'à hauteur de 4 millions d'euros
ensuite pour l'année 2023 sur la
décision de la première ministre nous
allons permettre en place un amortisseur
d'électricité pour toutes les PME moins
250 salariés elles auront une réduction
de leur facture en moyenne de 20%. si
jamais si jamais cela ne suffit pas nous
sommes prêts à regarder ce qu'il doit
être mis en place de complémentaires
pour aider un certain nombre de
solutions qui sont confrontées à des
situations particulières les boulangers
en font partie vous allez prendre en
charge 20% seulement de la hausse du cou
alors moi je vais vous donner un exemple
très concret une boulangerie payait 1500
euros par mois de frais d'électricité
cette facture passe à 4500 euros sur les
4500 euros vous allez en prendre à peu
près 900 euros en charge ça veut dire
qu'il lui reste 3600 euros à payer cette
boulangerie sont deux deux à travailler
toute la journée de 4 heures du matin à
19h le soir et bien c'est 3600 euros de
frais d'électricité ils ne peuvent pas
les absorber aujourd'hui et ils vont
fermer début janvier 2023 monsieur le
ministre il y a déjà dans mon
département 5 boulangeries qui ont fermé
il faut que le tarif réglementé soit mis
en place tout de suite sans attendre
monsieur le ministre sans attendre il y
a quelques jours le gouvernement a donné
instruction au préfet de département de
préparer des scénarios de délestage en
cas de tension grave sur nos réseaux
d'électricité
l'objectif de cette mesure vise à
prévenir tout risque de coupure
généralisée en janvier qui impacterait
trop fortement le fonctionnement de
notre pays nos concitoyens nos
entreprises nos industries effectuent
depuis plusieurs jours depuis plusieurs
semaines des efforts de sobriété pour
rationaliser nos consommations d'énergie
nous savons tous que notre politique de
sobriété devrait nous permettre de
passer cet hiver sans coupure
d'électricité
d'ailleurs le scénario d'un délestage au
mois de décembre a été écartée par RTE
pour dissiper toutes fake news à ce
sujet quelle mesure sont prévues pour
ces télésage comment votre gouvernement
va les anticiper je vous remercie je
peux vous assurer monsieur le député que
le gouvernement est mobilisé depuis des
mois cette mobilisation se conduit avec
ordre méthode et dans l'anticipation
se mobiliser c'est d'abord nous appuyer
sur EDF et j'ai eu à plusieurs reprises
Luc Raymond le nouveau président de
cette entreprise depuis sa prise de
fonction et je peux vous garantir qu'il
partage la détermination du gouvernement
pour assurer une production
d'électricité maximale de notre
opérateur national en particulier grâce
aux redémarrage de nos réacteurs
nucléaires se mobiliser c'est aussi
travailler pour identifier tous les
gisements de production et d'économie
possible dans une période où la tension
sera maximale sur notre réseau c'est
partager également avec nos concitoyens
l'impératif de sobriété comme le
président de la République l'a fait dès
l'été dernier et les Français ont
parfaitement compris cette nécessité
puisque la consommation a baissé de 7% à
météo
identique ce mobiliser c'est aussi la
solidarité européenne nous avons
sécurisé nos interconnexions avec nos
voisins c'est d'ailleurs le sens de
l'accord que j'ai signé avec le
chancelier allemand il y a dix jours et
puis enfin anticiper cet examiner tous
les scénarios fustent-ils inédit fustile
improbable bien évidemment les préfets
en lien avec les collectivités et les
associations et tu dis comment protéger
les Français notamment les plus
vulnérables et contrairement à ce que
des propos maladroits ont pu laisser
penser nos hôpitaux seront toujours
alimentés en électricité et les
personnes malades à domicile seront
toujours prises en charge devant les
menaces de coupure d'électricité et
l'improvisation de votre plan de
délestage notre colère est forte
notre colère est froide l'hiver vient et
nous nous savons rien sur la manière
dont nous allons traverser cette sale
période ceux qui ont froid l'hiver le
savent déjà
vous avez montré votre incurie devant
l'explosion des prix qui font mal aux
vies aux industries aux agriculteurs en
vous révélant incapable totalement
incapable de reprendre la main sur le
marché pour protéger le pays mais voilà
que votre impuissance consenti à
incarner un état stratège qui vous
conduit désormais à souffler le chaud et
le froid entre l'alarme aux coupures en
même temps que l'invitation à ne pas
paniquer pour mieux masquer votre
impréparation vous infantilisez les
Français vous les humilier vous les
menacer de couper le jus s'ils ne sont
pas exemplaires nous accusons le
président de la République et son
gouvernement d'irresponsabilité
énergétique nous accusons le président
de la République et son gouvernement de
n'avoir rien fait pendant les 8
dernières années pour éviter
l'effondrement de nos capacités de
production nous accusons le président de
la République et son gouvernement de se
résigner à gérer peur à défaut de savoir
gérer la crise la France vous le savez
se prépare depuis 9 mois à faire face à
cette crise énergétique qui n'a rien de
français puisque c'est une crise
européenne
lorsqu'on dépend à 40 % des livraisons
de gaz de la Russie et lorsque 20% de
l'électricité européenne est produite à
base de gaz par construction nous avons
une crise et c'est ce pays qui a été
l'un des premiers à remplir ces stocks
de gaz au maximum c'est ce pays qui a
pris des mesures au niveau et qui a
conduit des mesures au niveau européen
pour faire face précisément et nous
mettre en situation de passer l'hiver
dans les meilleures conditions de
préparation alors Monsieur jumelles
plutôt que de nourrir l'angoisse et
l'anxiété des Français
aidez-nous à mobiliser les entreprises
les administrations les collectivités
locales pour continuer dans la baisse de
leur consommation d'énergie et des nous
à soutenir les salariés d'EDF de RTE
denedis de GrDF qui sont aujourd'hui au
travail pour augmenter notre production
d'électricité et pour sécuriser nos
stocks de gaz pourquoi nous préparons
nous au scénario du pire parce que nous
avons la responsabilité d'anticiper
toutes les situations et en
responsabilité nous travaillons à
protéger les Français en protégeant leur
pouvoir d'achat et en protégeant leur
accès à l'énergie une seconde
vous préparez le scénario du pire et
vous êtes le pire des scénarios
le 25 novembre dernier la France et
l'Allemagne ont scellé un accord
d'échange la France devant livrer une
partie de ses réserves de gaz contre de
l'électricité allemande un accord aux
abords simple mais au contour flou et
imprécis malgré nos questions
récurrentes en commission dans
l'hémicycle ou à Matignon lors
d'entretien avec Marine Le Pen vous
refusez de donner les conditions
précises d'application de cet accord la
France livre déjà depuis mi-octobre son
gaz c'est un fait quelles sont les
conditions économiques et financières de
cet accord quelles sont les obligations
réelles de l'Allemagne sur leur
livraison d'électricité
nous nous inquiétons car des personnes
chez EDF nous ont alerté que les
Allemands prétextes régulièrement des
problèmes techniques pour ne pas nous
livrer de l'électricité quand notre
réseau est sous tension ces incertitudes
sont scandaleuses quand on voit le
risque de coupure d'électricité et
l'explosion des coûts de la facture
énergétique de nos entreprises avec le
RN on n'est jamais déçu car quand il
s'agit d'agiter les peurs et d'affoler
les Français on trouve toujours fort à
prendre par contre quand il faut en
responsabilité voter un projet de loi
qui permet de produire de l'électricité
bas carbone compétitive là on a plus de
répondant ça c'est le vrai visage du
rassemblement national nous soutenons
l'ensemble de l'Union européenne en
exportant du gaz nous le faisons aux
conditions du marché vous m'interrogez
sur l'accord avec l'Allemagne il se
trouve que ça concerne ses exportations
de gaz nous le faisons aux conditions du
marché et cela nous permet de garantir
une meilleure production d'électricité
sur l'ensemble de l'Europe puisque 20%
de l'électricité européenne est produite
à base de gaz deuxième élément
s'agissant des engagements de
l'Allemagne je veux vous préciser ici
que l'Allemagne s'est engagée à
prolonger l'utilisation leur centrale
nucléaire qui sont aujourd'hui en base
pour 300 grammes nucléaires et qui
permet justement de sécuriser les
interconnexions avec la France cet
accord-là nous l'avons arraché avec le
président de la République et la
première ministre et ce qui nous permet
là encore en sécurité d'affronter dans
les meilleures conditions l'hiver
2022 est aussi marqué par des questions
qui touchent directement le quotidien
des Français notamment la pénurie de
médicaments ou encore le coût de la vie
en outre-mer
il est temps de tirer la sonnette
d'alarme face à la pénurie de
médicaments une situation inquiétante
qui ne fait que s'aggraver dans ma
circonscription de laine comme dans
toute la France d'ailleurs d'après un
rapport d'activité 2021 de l'Agence
nationale pour la sécurité du médicament
et des produits de santé la rupture au
risque de rupture de stock concerne
2160 références de médicaments en 2021
contre 871 en 2017 si je vous dis trois
virus circulent covid 19 grip bon cul
Lite vous concentrez si je vous dis
insuffisance du gouvernement ou chez la
tête pourtant les tensions sur
l'approvisionnement du médicament ne
sont pas nouvelles antibiotiques
antalgique anti-inflammatoire tous les
médicaments sont concernés nous payons
le prix de la délocalisation de nos
usines et de nos laboratoires qui dans
ce domaine aussi nous rend de plus en
plus dépendant d'autres pays qui eux ont
fait le choix de leur souveraineté la
question sera donc la suivante monsieur
le ministre quand et comment
comptez-vous remédier à cette pénurie de
médicaments qui touche l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes je vous remercie notre
système de surveillance justement en
France via l'agence du médicament que
vous avez cité nous permet d'alerter que
nous descendons nos stocks en dessous de
1 mois pour les médicaments les plus
utilisés c'est donc pas que nous n'en
n'avons plus mais nous avons un stock
qui est insuffisant alors quelle mesure
ont été prises empêchées de vendre à
l'étranger des produits qui sont déjà en
France empêcher les grossistes de vendre
ses produits en stock à l'étranger
assurer une meilleure répartition
territoriale en fonction des grossistes
en demandant par exemple dans le cas du
doliprane pédiatrique aux pharmaciens de
ne plus commander au laboratoire mais
commander directement chez les
grossistes pour cette répartition
mobiliser également les sociétés
savantes dans le cadre de traitement
alternatif puisque vous savez bien que
même pour les antibiotiques il y a des
possibilités de traitement alternative
de façon systématique enfin la
remise en place la relocalisation en
France de la production de médicaments
dans le cas de plantes du plan France
2030 porté par le gouvernement va nous
amener progressivement à rapatrier les
principes actifs les plus importants en
particulier de l'iprane de l'année
prochaine mais de quoi parle-t-on
aujourd'hui principalement en termes de
pénurie de médicaments nous parlons du
doliprane pédiatrique ce doliprane
pédiatrique et fabriqué en Allemagne
essentiellement par sanofiste un conflit
social chez Sanofi qui a amené une
diminution des productions des
productions de diminution de la
distribution le conflit social est réglé
nous devrions rentrer dans des
conditions satisfaisantes de stock dans
les semaines qui contiennent
l'amoxicilline est plus compliquée c'est
une pénurie mondiale c'est lié à un
défaut de production en tout cas un
défaut d'anticipation des producteurs et
là il faudra entendre quelques semaines
encore voir quelques mois lors de
l'examen du budget outre-mer l'unité des
députés ultramarins était mise au delà
des clivages politiques pour dénoncer
l'urgence de la situation en outre-mer
l'ensemble de notre travail a été balayé
d'un revers de main par votre troisième
49.3 qui a rejeté la quasi-totalité de
nos amendements avant cela déjà les
débats sur la loi pouvoir d'achat
avaient montré le peu d'engagement du
gouvernement sur la question de la
pauvreté et de l'inflation d'outre-mer
dernier en date ludino du pouvoir
d'achat nous laisse à nouveau un goût
amer le résultat n'est clairement pas à
la hauteur des besoins si vous aviez
pris soin de nous consulter nous aurions
assurément été force de proposition
les différentes exemples qui ont jalonné
le début de cette mandature laisse ainsi
percevoir le mépris du gouvernement
mépris pour le travail des
parlementaires outre-mer mépris
également pour la situation alarmante
des territoires ultramarins frappés par
l'inflation dans un contexte préexistant
de grandes pauvreté aussi monsieur le
ministre je m'interroge pour la suite de
la législature avez-vous l'intention
d'engager une véritable discussion dans
un esprit de co-construction terme cher
à notre première ministre une véritable
discussion disait-je avec les députés
ultramarins pour trouver des solutions
qui ne soient pas un simple pansement
sur une plaie béante l'inflation dans
votre territoire par exemple de la
Réunion mais dans l'ensemble des
outre-mer et deux tours de 7%. nous
avons d'une part revaloriser évidemment
les prestations sociales ou les aides
alimentaires de 4 à 5% et des sur
l'énergie encore plus d'ailleurs qu'en
grande partie qu'en métropole notamment
sur l'essence et c'est parfois
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements internes au
fonctionnement ultramarin à l'exception
de Mayotte qui nous le péché de faire
des prix beaucoup plus bas à la demande
de certains élus vous le savez
parfaitement pour des questions de
concurrence troisièmement le bouclier
pris qualité mis en place par le dino du
port d'achat par le ministre des
Outre-mer a permis sur 1503 produits de
première nécessité et de fonctionnement
du quotidien des ultramarins de ne pas
connaître d'inflation ça n'existe pas en
métropole avouez que c'est à la fois
remarquable d'avoir gagné ça avec 153
entreprises et notamment en lien avec
les transporteurs et je pense assez mal
CGM en revanche madame la député je suis
preneur de l'aide des collectivités
territoriales
ultramarines pour permettre que l'autre
droit de mer qui malheureusement
augmente l'inflation des produits
importés contribue peut-être par une
forme de pondération de cet octrère au
fait que pour vos concitoyens l'addition
soit moins salée également ce que je
remarque c'est que les mesures sont
remarquablement insuffisantes
effectivement l'inflation est peut-être
en deçà de ce que l'on peut constater
dans l'Hexagone mais le taux de pauvreté
lui est bien de ça de ce que l'on peut
constater ici 38% des Réunionnais vivant
dessous du seuil de pauvreté c'est 50%
en Guyane plus de 70% dans le
département de Mayotte et vous nous
indiquez que le BQ plus le bouclier qui
a été pris plus effectivement
permettrait de remédier à ça à la
Réunion il existe depuis l'année
dernière il n'a pas été revalorisé par
ludino on doit se contenter d'une
diminution des taxes sur les colis
envoyés entre particuliers c'est pas
avec une diminution des taxes sur ses
colis que les Réunionnais parviendront à
remplir leur assiette vous ne répondez
pas à la question l'octroi de mer qui a
un impôt qui dépend des collectivités
locales s'il était baissé ce serait
directement du pouvoir d'achat en plus
pour vos concitoyens faites votre part
nous avons fait la nôtre
13 décembre 2022 dernière séance de
questions au gouvernement de l'année un
autre sujet commence à raisonner à
l'Assemblée nationale la réforme des
retraites les oppositions sont vent
debout contre le report de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite voulu par
Emmanuel Macron dans un échange au
vitriol Mathilde panot chef de fil des
députés de la France insoumise dénoncent
une odieuse réforme ce qui lui vaut une
réponse musclée de la première ministre
Elisabeth borne
la moitié des pauvres ont moins de 30
ans un tiers sont des enfants 42
000 d'entre eux sont à la rue dans le
froid ou en hébergement précaire les
Français renoncent au chauffage leurs
enfants n'ont plus de desserts à la
cantine de piscine ou de vacances mais
vive la retraite à 65 ans les coupures
d'eau prive des centaines d'enfants
ultramarins d'un mois et demi d'école
par an les médicaments viennent à
manquer sont rationnés en pharmacie
pénurie de place en crèche d'aesh de
chauffeur de car de professeurs de
soignants mais vive la retraite à 65 ans
10 millions de pauvres et 19
millionnaires au gouvernement la santé
et la vie chère sont les priorités de
80% des Français cette année un Français
sur cinq a renoncé à offrir des cadeaux
de Noël mais vive la retraite à 65 ans
oui vive la retraite à 65 ans même si
huit Français sur 10 sont contre votre
effort même si le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites ni tout impératif
budgétaire vive la retraite à 65 ans et
tant pis si 7 millions de personnes sont
déjà mortes à cet âge vous le savez
repoussez d'un mois la présentation de
votre réforme des retraites et l'aveu de
votre extrême fébrilité vous avez peur
et vous avez raison d'avoir peur
alors ma question est simple madame la
Première ministre
vous engagez-vous oui ou non à ne pas
avoir recours aux 49,3 pour imposer
votre Dieuze réforme
je pense que vous n'avez même pas
examiné les mesures des projets de loi
de finance qui vous ont été présentés
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Français vous n'avez pas voté la remise
carburant vous n'avez pas voté les
boucliers tarifaires vous n'avez pas
voté l'aide exceptionnelle de rentrer
donc nous n'avons pas de leçon à
recevoir madame la Présidente panneau
sur la protection du pouvoir d'achat des
Français le financement de notre système
de retraite est menacé
dès l'année prochaine il sera de nouveau
en déficit un déficit qui va se creuser
année après année qui atteindra 12
milliards en 2027 et près de 20
milliards en 2035 ce chiffre ce sont
ceux du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites un organisme dont vous aimez
vous réclamez alors face à cette menace
qui pèse sur notre système
deux chemins se dessinent le premier
c'est celui que vous avez en commun avec
le rassemblement national la démagogie
les promesses inconséquentes le retour à
la retraite à 60 ans mais votre promesse
a un coût 38 milliards d'euros par an
même en sacrifiant les pensions des
retraités même en augmentant les impôts
c'est une promesse intenable la réforme
panneau Le Pen c'est plus d'impôts moins
de pouvoir d'achat pour les retraités et
il menace pour les retraites des plus
jeunes car notre modèle social ne serait
plus financé alors madame la Présidente
panneau
le chemin de la responsabilité nous
refusons d'augmenter les cotisations
nous refusons de faire baisser les
pensions nous voulons au contraire les
augmenter pour assurer la pérennité de
notre système de retraite alors même que
nous vivons plus longtemps oui nous
proposons de travailler progressivement
un peu plus longtemps nous n'avons pas
nous n'avons pas masqué nous l'avons
affirmé dès la campagne présidentielle
mais je n'envisage pas de mener cette
réforme sans concertation plusieurs
cycles ont eu lieu sous l'autorité du
ministre du Travail et j'ai moi-même
rencontré ces derniers jours les
organisations syndicales et patronales
de nos échanges émergent une volonté de
poursuivre le dialogue c'est pourquoi
comme l'a annoncé le président de la
République nous avons décidé de
poursuivre ses concertations pendant
quelques semaines et en janvier compte
tenu des échanges que nous aurons eu je
présenterai notre projet de réforme de
retraite madame la Première ministre oui
ou non le 49.3 pour imposer votre
réforme des retraites vous n'avez pas
répondu
[Applaudissements]
la réforme des retraites qui deviendra
le sujet numéro un à l'Assemblée
nationale à partir de janvier 2023
jusqu'à la promulgation de la réforme en
avril un système ce numéro des grands
débats à très vite sur LCP pour revoir
une autre séance
[Musique]